hey youtubers surprise surprise they
confirm the season for villain is going
to be devote the thinker so we got to
freak out about this I changed the audio
just a little bit so let me know if you
think the audio on this video sounds
better than the previous videos that
I've done but there's a new brand of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so surprised or
not surprised I guess DeVoe seems like
he's going to be the main villain
TVLine was reporting that it was a done
deal Andrew Kreisberg said way back
during PaleyFest yeah we've already
decided we're not going to do a
speedsters the main villain for season 4
it will very literally blow the Flash's
mind like that you've probably seen me
use this picture in my flash videos
before the thinker is a mind control
villain he uses technology for mind
control and telekinesis so this is
obviously from the Geoff Johns era but
he debuted way back in all-flash during
the 1940s so this is the classic version
of devote double bonus this was during
the Jay Garrick era so hopefully they'll
find some really cool Jay Garrick
stories to tell I think they had a
couple of cool moments within this past
season but I was a little disappointed
we didn't see him even more
so obviously this story is more of like
a crime thriller that's what a lot of
the Batman stories were when they first
started it was just a lot of Dick Tracy
style detective stories so you have Jay
Garrick here trying to foil these
mobsters he sends one of them to jail
the other mobsters say we've got
somebody who can quash that to vote
he'll get rid of that confession so
obviously very very different from the
Geoff Johns version like the way they
did with abracadabra it'll be a more
contemporary looking version with a lot
of flair and verbal references for the
really classic silly stuff so I'm not
expecting him to walk in looking like he
came right out of the Ghostbusters movie
but there been a couple different ways
that they've used him in the comics but
he did show up with the Suicide Squad he
actually tried to organize a big prison
break in the classic comics there's just
a lot of stories he's been involved with
to share things in common with what the
flash has been doing the last season
setting things up for next year that
gorilla grodd version of The Suicide
Squad he was in Belle Reve with the
Suicide Squad back during the new 52 as
the difference with this version is that
his intellect is actually sapping his
age like it's literally eating himself
alive so he's like this 25 year old kid
in the body of an old
man so I'm just expecting some middle
ground like I don't think he's going to
walk into season four with a bunch of
things sticking out of his head
maybe by the end of the seasons they do
some pretty crazy stuff but if they
didn't give abracadabra like the full-on
top hat that I'm not expecting them to
do that with a thinker either just
because they always borrow so much stuff
from geoff johns era on the flash if you
want to read a really good story with
them start with flash vol 2 number 183
that goes through 191 it's just called
flash crossfire it was his fourth big
arc so there were probably some big
changes from this but I do love the way
it plays out because you have a version
of Clifford DeVoe like he tells his
backstory here when he's talking to the
Wally West versions of Flash
remember most of Geoff Johns run was
with the Wally West flash before he
brought him back during rebirth in 2009
so this is all happening way back in
2002 but he takes over all of Keystone
City in sort of plugs himself into
everyone because he's trying to expand
his mind so the flash makes a deal with
them you can plug into my mind the
world's fastest data processor is the
Flash's brain so that is what this
iconic image that you keep seeing is
it's the flash who's been taken over
with the mind of DeVoe but he's kind of
doing this to everyone in Keystone City
and that's why Wally makes this bargain
with him this is where it starts to get
weird so all the rogues of Keystone City
come to face the thinker he turns his
army of mind-control followers on them
but they're able to get the flash away
so he's not being mind-controlled
anymore in what Wally does in order to
defeat him you've seen how Barry can
take in information at SuperSpeed and
hold on to it for about a half hour at a
time so Wally uses his ability to draw
the thinker into his mind and defeat him
in his own territory and this is where
it gets really cool it basically turns
into an episode of the matrix so like I
said this issue was around 2002 Geoff
Johns probably went to the movie theater
in 99 saw the matrix and was like hey
wait a minute that'd be pretty badass if
I could turn that into a flash story so
Wally tells him that because there in
his mind he has complete control he can
fight tuvo with all of his memories
everyone he's ever known so it's like
this super speedster matrix team-up but
it's all happening in Wally's mind so
have ginger Wally West from earlier in
his timeline punching him here so I
don't know if the flash TV show would
ever get quite as trippy as that but
you'd have to imagine Barry making his
own version of the Speed Force wormhole
aliens set where he just conjures
anything that he wants to fight to vote
but I don't think they're going to do an
episode of the matrix because that was
very contemporary back in 2002 but
nowadays it feels kind of silly but it
is a pretty badass twist I'm going to
pull you into my mind and you're going
to have to fight every single speedster
that I've ever met in there a couple big
action set pieces like you see Wally
have to repair a bridge but in order to
do that he has to go read all these
books on construction at SuperSpeed then
rebuild the bridge is this is all
falling apart you've seen all those
episodes of the flash where they do the
big BIST
the bridge that connects Keystone in
Central City this was the flash story
where Wally West built that bridge
permanently connecting them and like he
says here permanently under my
protection so it's not something you
think about when you see big maps like
this as a city on the TV show but that
was actually a big flash story that rose
out of the connecting of Central City
and Keystone City Central City being
Barry Allen City Keystone City being
Wally West city and then later Wally and
Linda find out that they're pregnant so
obviously there's like a lot of big
things that the flash TV show could pick
from a storyline like this but it just
depends on what they want the thinker to
look like like do they actually want
them to be a digital person that would
be really weird to not have somebody
that you couldn't punch in the face at
least a little bit so they'll probably a
combination of things but you have a
situation where DeVoe is at both times
controlling the Rogues and fighting them
himself
so like the season on the flash he
worked with Captain Cold
you've seen times when they fought each
other there's all manner of crazy things
they could do and that doesn't even get
into the Gorilla Grodd version of The
Suicide Squad what a coincidence that
were fighting somebody with mind-control
abilities wouldn't it be helpful if we
had somebody who also had my control
abilities that could help us out with
that so that's just your back door to
Gorilla Grodd doing a Captain cold type
twist where he's forced to work with
team flash for his freedom or for
whatever bargain it is that he wants to
make we'll have to do some Grodd Caitlin
videos this summer Caitlin is one of the
only people that he would
it'd be really nice to so maybe Caitlin
will help convince him to help out team
flash but it's a really good opportunity
to do a giant Rogues based story with a
villain that's able to work with them
but you can also bring back all the old
favorites too so you can do your Grodd
episode you can even do reverse flash
but it doesn't have to be the main
villain but because the main goal of
DeVoe in the comics with this Geoff
Johns story was just to expand his
processing power to the minds of
everybody everywhere like he literally
wanted to become everything because he
transcended his physical body it's like
that really bad Johnny Depp movie
transcendence they're probably not going
to do that on the TV show but let me
know what do you guys want them to do
with the de veau character which version
do you want him to look like do you want
him to be the cyberspace version do you
want him to be the new 52 version with
all those crazy nodules sticking out of
his brain or do you think he's just
going to look like a normal person with
a bunch of tech so either way just
really surprised that they're dropping
all this information so early
but what's happening later tonight is
I'm going to see Wonder Woman again I'll
probably be posting a couple more videos
for that in the next couple of days so
I'll do like a video for the ending
explain how it ties in with Justice
League all the Easter eggs so be sure
and go see it but I'll announce a new
winner for the flash ring giveaway when
I post that next video so while you wait
for that click here for my non-spoilery
Wonder Woman review and you can click
here for all my season 4 videos thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight